من موظف الى ملحن ومطرب بيت ثلاث دقات فتح
باب النجوميه اصبح له معجبين في كل مكان
ومن كل الاعمار بعدها اصدر عددا من
الاغنيات التي حققت شهره كبيره بما فيها
اغنيه حبيبي يا ليل التي حققت عشره ملايين
مشاهده على يوتيوب خلال 24 ساعه فقط ضيفنا
اليوم في صباح العربيه المطرب والملحن ابو
نتعرف اكثر على طريقه نشر اغانيه بفصل
الاغاني الفرديه عن البومات وهل هي سبب
نجاح اعماله اليوم ايضا سيطلق معنا اغنيته
الجديده ونتعرف اكثر مع ابوه على خططه
المستقبليه
[موسيقى]
بحب كده وعلى مدى التاريخ كل واحد هيمشي
اكتر في المشوار هتروح هيبقى مش ابو ثلاث
دقات هيطلع حاجات ثانيه طيب هو في ناس
يعني تصدر اغنيه سنجل تنجح بعدين يختفون
انت توقعت اغنيه بعدها تحقق عشر ملايين
مشاهده بنفس النجاح واكثر حبيبي يا ليل
اقول لك حاجه انا بالنسبه لي نجاح او
مقياس النجاح مش هتجيبك بايه نجاح هو
الاستمراريه في 24 ساعه اه حبيبي يا ليل
جابت 10
ملايين في 24 ساعه
وكانت بالنسبه لي حاجه تخض برضو بس عمري
في حياتي والله ما بلتفت لمين جاب كام حتى
في عز من ثلاث دقات كانت
مولعه الدنيا تمام يعني انا اهم حاجه
بالنسبه لي ان انا انزل الاغاني اللي انا
عايز انزلها واكمل في الاستمراريه نجاح
مهم ولكن الاستمرار هي الاهم طيب انت يا
ابو شو شعورك انه اغانيك وصلت لكوريا
كوريا الجنوبيه يعني فرقه بي اي جي
الكوريه الجنوبيه وهي مشهوره كمان كثير
نشرت فيديو لاغنيه ثلاث دقات على
لكن لذيذ قوي انبسطت في الموضوع ده هو خلي
بالك هي اتعملت قبر روسي وامريكاني
فدي كانت حاجه دي احلى حاجه في المزيكا ان
حتى لو مش بيفهم لغه اللحن
فيك تختار اغاني اتنزلها سينجلز شو سر
نجاحها ليش اخترت هالطريق تحديدا الطريقه
دي انا اخترتها علشان على عكس زمان ما حدش
بقى بيسمع يعني اخر مره انت مسكتي البوم
شخص وسمعتيه كله ايه
سريع قوي عايزين نسمع مش عارفين بعد كده
فكره ان تنزلي بقلبهم بقت قليله قوي بقت
مور ارتستك عنها كوميرشن
بس انا ان شاء الله السنه دي في الصيف ده
هنزل بقى البوم يعني هاحمل لاول مره لقلبه
عشان ارتست محتاج ان انا انزل حاجه
[موسيقى]